The joe rogan experience.
Jamie's giving me the Nah,
sure.
Look,
yes.
You and Joey Diaz talking about doing a show in in New York.
Where do you man?
Oh,
okay.
You don't talk about it.
Yeah,
no need to find one here.
I got a joint Diaz story.
We're going to do a show with me and Joey and Eol motherfucking Romero and he's
going to talk to him if he gets confused and in Spanish because Joey's from
Cuba.
Dude,
are you kidding me?
[inaudible] going to translate.
He was Joe.
It's totally Joey's idea.
Joey says,
bro up and talking to them.
I love this fucking guy.
We'd have an amazing podcast.
You wouldn't be,
you prone the questions Adam,
if shit gets,
we'd,
I come to him when in Spanish.
We'll understand each other better to proline ideas.
What Joey said,
he said,
uh,
he goes,
tell him that I want to be on his podcast because he has love for Cuba in under,
he understands Cuban love.
Love.
It was like that.
All that shit that he was doing a Luke Rockhold after he knocked him out was a
tense up that's in town.
Give me a few minutes.
You just knocked me into fricking.
That's intense.
The gimme a fucking second to get my wits about me and then kiss me on the lips
or wherever the fuck you want to do it.
His ability to just be calm and then explode.
It's very terrifying.
It's only helped by him telling you he loves you.
He's,
he's worked terrified.
They never,
it's scary cause he's such a nice guy outside dude.
He is the nicest car.
He's very friendly.
You remember the champ though was like,
oh yeah.
That's what you do.
You're Whitaker.
You know Whitaker is a monster man.
Gotta go back to that Tim Kennedy fight though.
Man.
Dot.
About stool gate.
Yeah.
That Tim Kennedy fight was crazy.
It was like,
look,
I know what you're doing.
It's very slick.
This is very smart.
I mean this is Angelo.
Dundee did that to Muhammad Ali when he fought Henry Cooper in London.
He got crack on the left hook.
Henry Cooper dropped him and he was in real trouble.
They cut the glove,
baby.
Cut that glove,
We got to get the other pair.
Oh,
it's out there in the dressing room.
Be Right back.
It's all fair in love.
And they go,
oh man.
Yeah,
it ain't the right way to do it.
But you got to,
you got to realize that this guy had gone through the whole amateur wrestling
system as a representative of Cuba.
What?
Matt Brown and I did a podcast last week and Matt Brown spat.
He's a great guy and fascinating dude,
man.
Intense smart motherfucker.
Peptide people get a chance to,
he did he die.
He died and they brought him back.
Yeah.
You know,
we talked about that you and court McGee both have this white creepy thing to
you because you both crossed over to the other side and you don't give a fuck.
How was it who?
Both guys,
man,
you've got to beat them.
They don't beat each other.
Literally have to take it on.
Beat themselves rather.
Yeah.
I mean,
Matt Brown a beaten himself like he's,
he's a human.
What's he doing now?
He is going to fight Carlos condit all that's right.
He's coming back from war.
He ended,
he ended on that dope ass knocked out of Diego.
The elbow maybe behind the air,
but all's fair a little bit.
And then I thought he was going to ride off into the sunset and now he's
fighting Carlos condit.
So he was explaining about his camp that he did in Cuba.
It's amazing story.
Amazing.
He spent like six weeks in cab brown.
Yes.
His wife Susan Cuba,
his white ass was in Cuba with the wrestling team for six fucking weeks for one
of the camps.
One of his fights,
he boxed in Cuba and Cuban boxers and he wrestled.
He lived in a Cuban fighters house.
They had them there and they fed which fight was it that he said?
I try to remember which fight,
if you pull up,
pull up his record.
It was fairly recently,
fairly recently doing that.
He's a bad motherfucker,
dude.
Bad motherfucker.
I'm not,
I'm not good at that.
Like I don't want anyone to lose.
Like,
I love Yoel Romero and I love Luke,
but I've been,
but I,
uh,
I know what those guys feel like when they lose and there's everything on the
table.
I know what for Luke,
how he changed camps and sometimes that's just you're on a boat and there's
holes and then you think if you pal further away from the original camp,
you know,
fill these holes and it doesn't work like that.
So I know by him leaving fresh look,
I mean it might've been a good move for him,
but he fought you all were marrow.
I mean the reality is yellow were marrow is fucking horrifying.
He's horrifying.
Luke can beat him.
Yeah,
he might be able to,
but he also might be able to get hit exactly what got hit in that fight every
time they fight.
Dude,
you don't know man.
I'm saying,
I don't know.
I've seen,
I've seen a better bs.
I've seen a better version of Luke to me as far as skill wise,
besides Whitaker.
Right now.
He's on another level,
but I look at the roster and to me,
Luke is the most complete middleweight in the world.
I can even seem be in the light heavyweight champion that's been like him.
Some problems besides gfes in there.
There's going to be some issues where those guys,
who knows maybe him going,
I mean he's been talking about an inevitable climb to two oh five he might be
just like Whitaker and just like,
um,
uh,
who else we're talking about?
Y'all failed Dos Anjos.
Yeah,
it might be.
He might be a better fighter.
Two Oh five he might be so fucking lean.
The problem there is what made Luke so great was that swagger,
like the people who were like,
oh,
he's so cocky.
I get that.
I actually want my fighter like that.
I liked how you so arrogant and cocky.
Sometimes people don't gravitate towards it,
but for a guy like Luke,
he just,
he thrived off that and now when I see him,
I,
you know,
when a is Latin in the branch fight,
I didn't see it as much.
I thought there that fight was a little suspect,
not taking anything away from branch,
but that should have been easier for Luke.
And I see the Yoel Romero fight and it just,
that killer instinct wasn't there.
He's very,
I know you have five rounds,
but he would let,
Yo will explode and reset when you reset.
You got to go when you've got to go.
Branch might not have the best results inside the octagon,
but when it comes to technical skill,
he's a super high level fighter.
His,
his skill level and his capabilities,
I don't think if matched up to all of his performances.
And you saw that when he's attacking Luke,
he's fucking good man.
He put him in real.
I'm not saying he's not.
Oh,
he's very,
I'm not saying that it's ground game is very good,
but it makes Luke's win even more impressive for sure.
With branches.
Never in world series of fighting.
He Kinda,
you know,
became light heavyweight champion middleweight champion.
He's a monster,
right?
Yeah.
In the UFC.
He just,
he hasn't found his groove yet,
right?
He did.
And he never has right now I don't,
you know,
a lot its level of competition.
You know,
his first fight in UFC was boring and then he'd get Luke Rockhold which snow
walk in the park.
So I do think Dave branch's a monster Henzel Gracie black belt,
second vert round in the UFC and correct Gerald Harris payload with that crazy
slam from the GAA.
Have a good career.
But yeah man.
Yeah that was,
that was crazy.
Gerald Harris is a powerful man.
Monster.
I'm,
I'm just saying w with Luke it was this swag or what he thought he was the best
in the world and was in Strikeforce is when he got to the UFC when he was
champion.
Right.
And then in the Biz being fight,
he gets clipped with that left hook and he has problems with the left,
the left side for him.
So you know,
Bisbing lands that knocks him out,
that short notice fight.
He thought he was going to walk through them.
They take that long layoff and he's,
he's trying to be a male model and you know,
arguing with the UFC,
it's just an in somewhere along the lines that he lost a little bit of swag when
he gets that back.
We're in good form.
Well um,
I'm curious to see what his journey with Henry Hoofed where that comes up cause
they've been,
how about how long have you been together now?
Like a year.
Maybe a year.
Yeah.
He moved out there.
Henry's an interesting coach,
man.
He's a fucking one or a bad guy.
He's a very powerful guy.
He doesn't have his DC and Cain Velasquez.
Right.
It could be right.
And Josh Thompson in this,
these monsters you're surrounded by just these monsters Susie training with and
how has he addressed that left side where it keeps getting hit.
You know which,
what put them out.
You will has left two labs.
Two left.
That upper cut.
Oh was like a free for all.
Like mark.
Got It.
Get a little closer.
You got to get a little closer.
That would have been hard to get all your marrow.
Just fucking think about is hitting as hard as you can.
Yeah,
you'll,
you'll run mill smash.
He's punching the humanist hard as they can.
I didn't think it was a bad stoppage because he had his head up when he went
down and you've got to give one guy a chance to hit.
I'm now looking at it after the fact.
You Go,
man,
I wish you didn't get hit with that upper cut.
The fight was already over,
but in the moment,
in real time,
it doesn't happen.
I'm talking shit.
Did I,
I hear you.
Unless you ran out four to 40 and again.
Oh,
I think it's a perfect stoppage.
I mean,
I think the first one,
you don't really stop it yet.
You got to see what's going on.
That's flat fucker.
You don't know.
You never know.
I hear you right.
That one you kind of know you kind of,
but after the fact we're saying that.
Yeah.
Okay.